the hell hey
come here come here this is uh mariel's
duck
no
no stupid idiot
hello everybody it's been a while since
i've done one of these face-to-face
videos listen uh this is gonna be an
update video about what's gonna happen
for next year so as of right now
my friends just because we should be
able to communicate haven't done these
videos in a while it feels weird i'm
talking to
a camera by myself
look like a [ __ ] idiot
i still don't wear pants but if you guys
have been listening to the genius brain
podcast you guys know starting next year
actually this week we are going only
once a week
now
that is pertaining on something so as of
right now i'm working on a deal
that'll allow genius brain to be going
twice a week but as of right now because
it's not done yet
it's going to be once a week i will let
you know
i'll let you know when we go twice a
week again but for now it's going to be
once a week so continue to watch it's
going to be out every sunday every
sunday at 12 p.m just to get you guys
through your week you know when i
started genius brain years ago i didn't
know what i was going to do with it and
actually about three years ago or so i
mean podcasts were just starting and i
really don't think it was that popular
and for me i didn't think it was going
to be a great move but it was something
that i i wanted to do and now everybody
and their [ __ ] mom has a podcast
so yeah your boy had foreskin foresight
but what i've noticed recently is that
being able to do a podcast has allowed
me to connect with this audience in a
way that i never have before so instead
of doing these small little videos where
i just talk about my [ __ ] real quick a
lot of people get to understand that i'm
really just a
[ __ ] idiot that just says a lot of
things or when i do try to say things i
can elaborate it past the three minute
video and you guys know that there's
been a lot of cancer culture going on so
if you can't explain yourself you don't
give people enough information people
are like canceled oh i got you you're
cancelled
what did you say something stupid in
your youth cancelled can't cancel me
[ __ ] i've been saying stupid [ __ ] i
never said i was smart you assumed but
thank you guys for watching geniusbrain
for these past three years the views
have been steady uh it's allowed me to
keep these lights on it's allowed me to
connect with you guys and also too by
the way as an update we sold so much of
our secret society gear it's unreal you
know when i did the podcast about secret
society and um i wanted to convey to you
guys the reason why i do a lot of things
or when i create a brand i think it
resonated with a bunch of you and for
those of you who have received your
secret society gear i i know you guys
know i'm not full of [ __ ] i know i'm so
confident in the [ __ ] that i do when i
put it out that i i can put my money
where my [ __ ] mouth is when you guys
receive like for example this
heavyweight t which sold out by the way
is nothing like any other ones that you
guys had i get it
we [ __ ] do dope [ __ ] now are our
margins as great as other clothing
companies probably not but i'm not gonna
[ __ ] put out [ __ ] that i'm not gonna
wear i just refuse i'm not doing that
later on there might be a secret society
slash genius brain collab piece keep thy
keep the thy ear out but i wanted to
take this time to say thank you we are
starting a new year next year and if
you've noticed the reason why i'm doing
these videos is because guess what next
year i am going to be doing youtube
videos again i don't know what the [ __ ]
is going to be it's just going to be me
having fun and i've i've i've realized
over the past few years there's a reason
why i always come back to youtube is
because youtube was a place for me to
feel safe it was a place for me to
create content however the [ __ ] i wanted
without somebody telling me how to do it
next year it's going to be fun genius
brain is going to be still going on
i'll tell you this
exciting exciting times because we're
going to be evolving we're going to be
growing and just like every year that
you guys supported me i'm always going
to be trying to do new things so thank
you for sticking around thank you for
really just supporting everything that
i've done for the past like 11 years i
have been on this space for so long and
the only reason why i get to do what i
do and the opportunities that have come
to me has happened is simply because you
have supported me and there is
nothing in this world that i could say
besides at this moment we just thank you
like thank you so much i know a lot of
other people say it out there they're
out there living their lives but when i
sometimes when i think about it in my
bed i just
i start to tear up a little bit because
prior to doing youtube i really didn't
know what i was going to do aside doing
stand-up and being on this platform
allowed me to evolve and pursue things
outside of the things that i was capable
of so
thank you from the bottom of my heart
next year let's get it i know this
thursday there is no podcast but once we
start to get things going two a week may
or may not come back depending on the
deal that i might get with geniusbrain
so
keep me in your prayers i love you very
[ __ ] much and as a last note um i
literally just tweeted this [ __ ] but if
anybody [ __ ] tells me one more time
that caviar is the most delicious thing
that they've ever had you you shut the
[ __ ] up you have been lied to so much
you oh my god fish eggs
the best thing you've ever eaten that's
why i [ __ ] hate gordon ramsay
sometimes this [ __ ] over here sturgeon
caviar
my god this is
yeah it tastes good is it [ __ ] roll
your eyes to the back of your [ __ ]
head delicious it's fish eggs it's
delicious for fish eggs in the category
of fish eggs and you add it to something
else great but don't [ __ ] tell me
that every time i see you [ __ ] food
influencers you put a slice or truffle
on something
anyways that has nothing to do with what
we were talking about let's end this
with a positive note [ __ ] you
no i like you
how do i turn this off